i was wondering if they caught any of
the interview yesterday
um and if they had any reaction to what
um the couple has gone through
uh in regards particularly with what
they felt
in terms of the racism that they felt
well
let me first say that um obviously many
of us caught the interview
i don't have i don't have as many
americans did and many people around the
world um
you know megan mark markle uh is a
private citizen
and so is harry at this point um for
anyone
to come forward and speak about their
own struggles with mental health and
tell their own personal story
that takes courage that's certainly
something the president believes and
he's talked about the importance of
um you know in these
areas that they're committed to in the
future as well uh
we aren't going to provide additional
commentary from here on behalf of the
president or others
given these are private citizens uh
sharing their own story and their own
struggles
um and let me just reiterate that we
have a strong and abiding relationship
with the british people and a special
partnership with the government of the
united kingdom
on a range of issues and that will
continue uh go ahead
oh i'll go to you to steve next every
student sorry a couple questions
um on the timeline front the president
hit on this over the weekend but i'm
wondering if you should clarify
uh he said that americans will start to
see these stimulus checks
this month that that is the mind right
now um
even the tax season yeah there are
concerns about whether they are
do you have a time will it be a matter
of days
that americans will see these checks
this is certainly a very popular
question for understandable reasons uh
the treasury department um is working on
what this looks like and what the
processing looks like at present
friday we expect a large number of
americans to receive relief uh by the
end of the month
but in terms of the mechanics of it the
treasury just has to work through that
and
and an update will likely come from them
but we'll keep you all abreast of it on
the vote count a little bit um
you didn't get a single republican vote
does this concern the president about
the ability to pass his agenda going
forward what are the implications
long term right now given that he
doesn't have any republican support for
this
well first the door of the oval office
remains open to bipartisan work
and i expect he will continue to work
with and reach out to
democrats of course but also republicans
about ways to work together and he's had
a number of bipartisan meetings
even in the last few weeks couple on
infrastructure on cancer
he feels there's a certainly is a path
forward uh but
we're also not going to allow
bipartisanship to be defined by
one zip code in fact many of the
republicans who voted against this
are outliers uh and are against the
grain of what the people in their own
districts supported
so uh they may be getting caught up once
they've got
when schools are able to upgrade
facilities and
you know benefit the x uh but
he remains open and remains hopeful
about the opportunity for bipartisan
work moving forward
with you on a question why has the white
house not said where this delegation
went this weekend
uh i can confirm for you that um that
the delegation went to
uh of course a cbp facility as was
confirmed in their readout but also to
the carrizo springs
uh facility a shelter in texas and why
so few details
on this release this this doesn't seem
to be in the transparency of
in the spirit of transparency that
secretary mayorkas promised here at this
platform there were no cameras there
were no press
julius answered very few details about
what they saw on that visit
well first the president she conveyed
asked them to go because he really
wanted to get a full assessment
from senior members of his policy team
about
what they were seeing on the ground
based on meetings based on conversations
with officials
from hhs officials who were running
these facilities about what their
challenges are what improvements could
be made and as she noted they also spoke
with children
uh they'll have as as is a normal part
of any internal policy process
uh they'll have a briefing uh with him
in the coming days we do look forward to
he's committed to we are all committed
to
allowing cameras into these facilities
but we want to figure out the best way
to do that protecting the privacy of the
kids
in a way that's secure and safe and uh
certainly that's something we
look to do in the future uh go ahead go
ahead steve
with the said that they discussed
capacity needs for unaccompanied
children
will they be making recommendations of
the president is there a need for
more capacity well we know just purely
by the numbers steve that there is going
to be a need right because we
have um a large number of kids
uh unaccompanied children who are coming
across the border
we've made a policy decision as an
administration that
uh the humane and moral approach is to
keep these safe and limitabilities safe
there are some limitations which i know
many of you are familiar with because of
covid restrictions and protocols
that reduce the capacity at a number of
these sites cdc also put out some
guidelines
many of you may have seen i believe it
was on thursday or friday
that will allow for increased capacity
at some of these sites
but it is an area it is an area of
policy discussion
how will we continue to accommodate in a
safe and humane way these kids
and our objective remains moving them as
quickly as possible
out of the border patrol facilities in
order to do that we need to have
shelter facilities that are safe that
have access to educational resources
legal resources
health and medical resources and we need
to ensure we have capacity to do that
the u.s has identified three online
publications directed by russia's
intelligence services aimed at
undermining the pfizer and modern
vaccines yeah you're what can you do
about this to counteract
well first we can reiterate that um we
will fight with every tool we have uh
disinformation we are certainly not
new to are we certainly familiar with i
should say uh the approach and
tactics of russian disinformation
efforts
and we will reiterate that at every
opportunity these vaccines are safe
they've been approved by the fda we will
have of course health and medical
experts conveying that at every turn
and we will uh our way to confirmation
europe we're monitoring it and we are
taking steps to address
go ahead you mentioned the uh historical
bipartisan nature of infrastructure has
situation
nations priority whether it will be a
targeted focused
infrastructure bill that could
potentially pick up republican support
or whether it's going to be a bigger
build back better
you know worse sweeping potentially more
expensive effort
not yet jeff it's a great question i
mean our focus i know we say this
publicly but it is also our focus
internally
is on uh is down the american rescue
plan
and getting it across the finish line
and we take nothing for granted
uh there are the the the president's
priorities are inaccurate he talked
about that
on a number of his agenda during the
campaign
infrastructure is one of them investing
in caregiving
doing more to improve access and expand
access to health care
adjusting our tax systems but the the
structure the size the format
that has not yet been determined um on
the
arp should we expect a signing ceremony
tomorrow or sometime after the
house passes it yeah i expect once
uh once we believe it's on the path to
the president
of course signing it and i certainly
would expect we'd take a moment to
answer what's the question sure that
low-income people who didn't file a tax
return because they make
they don't make enough income make sure
that they get the money because i think
in the last
go around in the previous administration
there were some eight people who were
intelligent
for the text for the tax benefits well
for the 1400
payments for the 1400 payments it's a
great question i probably would have to
talk to treasury about their
implementation mechanisms here
and how they they're able to reach those
individuals it certainly is something
that
we win reviews of processes that could
work better we also noted during the
transition but
i'll have to talk to about systems able
to
be in place to ensure more people
receive these checks
go ahead what are the president and
other white house officials doing today
to ensure that there are no democratic
defections in the vote tomorrow
well i will tell you having worked all
weekend as i think many of us did
um you know their uh our legislative
team led by steve
richetti and louise terrell are
certainly uh not taking anything for
granted they're picking up the phone
checking in with offices making sure
they have
their questions answered they're asking
the president the vice president
ron klain other senior members of the
administration to make calls
as needed i would say we feel it's on a
path
to passing the house and certainly
speaker pelosi has spoken to that but
uh we are at the ready everybody's on
call uh whenever they're needed and that
certainly applies to the president
now back on the filibuster uh senator
suggested over the weekend that the
filibuster be not
removed but reformed as someone who
spent decades
in the senate is that something that
president biden would be supportive of
well his preference is not to make
changes
to the filibuster uh uh rules uh
but believe that uh you can
democrats and republicans to get work
and business done he's also happy to
hear from
senator manchin and others who have
ideas about how to get
uh the done for the
senator manchin uh was also asked about
infrastructure and he
said that he felt that any big
infrastructure
package should be paid for and he
suggested that corporate tax hikes might
be
one way to pay for a massive
infrastructure
bill is does the president believe that
the bill should be paid for
and does he support corporate tax likes
is one way to do that
well he spoke on the campaign trail and
one of the items that he spoke about in
his build back better agenda was
making sure that people paid their fair
share uh whether it's highest income
or uh rolling back some of the corporate
tax cuts so certainly that's
in those are policies that he supports
we don't have a bill or a package yet
so well we can have that conversation
once we get there
one last question on schools dr fauci
said over the weekend that he thinks
that high schoolers are going to be
vaccinated by the fall
we know what president biden's schools
are when it comes to
k-5 kids have you made any progress in
devising goals
for high schoolers well we are thrilled
um to have secretary cardona confirmed
and he is
as you know going to be hosting an
education summit to talk about
the reopening of schools and look ahead
to what needs to be done to get that
done
and that applies of course not just to
k-5 or k-8 but also
high schools uh we also are on track to
sign into the for the president to sign
into law uh
the american rescue plan which is 160
billion dollars in it to
ensure that schools who don't have the
resources needed
can make these facility upgrades as well
get testing in place hire teachers
bus drivers but i will leave it to the
secretary of education to determine
uh the timeline or the path forward for
high schools
go ahead briefly ask them a couple of
code things can you confirm the
president will host
the merc and j executives at the white
house on wednesday
appropriate place to have the meeting uh
but he will look forward to discussing
with them
ways to work forward to continue to
expedite vaccine
supply and distribution to the american
people
the event was supposed to happen there
was of course a report on the weekend
over
the emergency history with the us
government is there any risk that
the i guess vaccine production could be
[Music]
um i guess problem with the merchant
being a supplier to j
j as implied by the president declined
to go to the facility
well uh i will say first that the
administration is going to undertake a
comprehensive
review and audit of the national
stockpile uh
but and obviously some of that was
covered in the story i believe you're
referencing
uh but i have not uh our health and our
cova team has not conveyed
uh to me any concern about the the
timeline or pace of vaccine production
your
team also just announced the new cdc
recommendations around vaccinated people
there's no change to travel guidance i
want to ask whether the white house have
any involvement
uh procedurally in preparing those or is
that entirely with the cdc but broadly
what do you say to americans who wonder
if i've been vaccinated
why can't they get on a plane i would
encourage them to ask the cdc the
questions they are the ones who
put together those guidelines we do not
we were not involved in the sense of
developing them or signing
off on them of course we receive regular
briefings but
uh you know i would direct those
questions to the cdc finally there was a
report out of
europe and eft that the european
commission will ask the us government to
authorize export of u.s
produced astrazeneca vaccines in
particular do you have any response to
that or can you say whether there have
been any calls that you've been asked
yet by the commission i don't have any
update on that josh it's a good question
but i'll have to talk to our national
security team and our cove
about what that process would look like
i'm not aware if that ask has actually
been initiated yet
go ahead yes jen thank you the chinese
foreign minister
is demanding that divided administration
falls former president trump's dangerous
practice
showing support for taiwan
uh what's your response to those words
from the
chinese well our foreign on taiwan
remains clear we will stand with friends
and allies to advance our shared
prosperity
security and values in the indo-pacific
region
we maintain our long-standing
commitments as outlined in the three
communiques the taiwan relations
act and the six assurances and we will
continue to assist
taiwan in maintaining a sufficient
self-defense capability so our position
remains the same are you worried at all
about this increasing
rhetoric and the actions by taiwan
towards china
i don't think i have anything more for
you on it uh go ahead katie
yeah question the first about uh
secretary clinton are being ordered to
visit the title angles they release
sexual misconduct on campus
so the trump era rules were
controversial because critics said they
bolstered the rights of the accused
perhaps over the rights of victims the
obama-era rules were met by legal
challenges
that said those rules infringed on due
process for the accused
where does the president want these
rules to go does he believe a violence
could be struck or what what is he
communicating about what he wants i mean
i think the president wants a
recommendation from the secretary of
education
uh who we look forward to having in this
briefing room and it sounds like there's
a lot of questions people would love to
ask him
but i don't think he's going to get
ahead of a policy process or
recommendations by his secretary of
education and then i have just a
question on what is the president's
relationship with senator manchin like
these days how often do they talk
they speak regularly he speaks with a
range of senators and members of
congress and members of the house
regularly as well obviously they have
meetings here but
um he perhaps for 30 years certainly
hesitate to pick up the phone and have a
conversation whether it's something he
agrees with disagrees with
um and that's something he's prone to do
even when it's not on his schedule for
that day
just when it comes up and it's an ask
somebody makes on the team
uh you know he has worked with senator
manchin over the course of course of
years and he certainly um appreciates
the support for
the 1.9 trillion dollar package that
will help bring
relief to the american people let's work
with him
on a range of items on his agenda moving
forward
go ahead uh the president said there'll
be enough vaccine supply to vaccinate
every american adult by the middle of
may
um what does that mean for the white
house's plan to
develop other rules to do export
vaccines to other areas in the world
well as the president has said and we've
said i guess
the our priority is ensuring that the
american people are vaccinated and we of
course remain
committed to being vital partners in the
global community
there are a couple of factors that we uh
our
certain team consider which vaccine is
most effective for children
of course that testing is ongoing uh
there we still don't know yet the impact
of all of the variants
so i don't have anything to predict for
you in terms of uh what additional
supply
will be shared and when and and the
process for that but certainly it's
something we're open to
our first priority though is ensuring
the american people are vaccinated
on this week's schedule every day has a
closely related event for the president
um obviously he's been focused on it on
any given week but this week it seems
notable
i was kind of curious what you could say
about what the plan is this week
and uh why this is kind of a special
week to kind of
increase that focus on the responsive
endowment
well i would say that there's no issue
more than getting the pandemic under
control the american people know
that the reason why we have a recession
the reason why
so many families are concerned about
putting food on the table the reason why
parents around the country are worried
about the impact of
closed schools on their kids mental
health and and their
their learning uh is because of the
pandemic and
it is the number one issue and priority
on the mind of the president the vice
president and our entire team
of course this week marks one year since
the country was
essentially shut down as a result
and it's important to
of course what what steps have been
taken and what progress has been made
but of course also the road ahead and so
we're taking an opportunity to do that
go ahead as a face principler i'm gonna
ask a question
for myself and behalf of the april sure
um and my first question for me
could be a follow-up to the mansion
question okay uh the senate
after before proof saturday
defeated an amendment that would have uh
defunded schools and universities under
under title ii if they allow uh
transgender kids
in athletics uh however that amendment
got support from senators on both sides
of the aisle including susan collins and
joe manchin
as head of the democratic party did the
president express any regret
that that measure got bipartisan support
well first let me say the president's
position on the right
on its is clear he sends an executive
order
uh and he believes transgender rights
are human rights and wants to
give the opportunity to play sports and
participate in a range of activities
um uh i would say um
uh we expected as there often is with
vodaramas there to be a range of
amendments that he would oppose
um and this certainly would have been
one of them uh but i don't have anything
more to
to read out for you in terms of his
specific concerns from my colleague
who asks given that multiple members of
president biden's staff
going to the u.s mexico border on
saturday or went there
why didn't the president make the trip
to see the situation himself and can we
expect to
visit the border for him in the coming
weeks ahead i don't have anything
anything on his schedule to read out i
will though confirm for you having
traveled on
smaller delegations but also on trips to
the president a trip with the president
as many of you know
includes air force one includes an
extensive security includes all of you
of course includes a large swath of
people and human beings
this was a trip with a small delegation
meant to be able to have a small
footprint on the ground to really
have conversations with people who are
working in these facilities who are
leading the the efforts underway and
even some
some children and it felt he felt it was
most appropriate for
members of his policy staff to have
those conversations and do the first
trip
go ahead the labor joe mansion
but what we saw last week was you guys
have a numbers problem and
potentially um a big one
what does that mean going forward again
joe manchin's comments in the past
and then more recently talking about he
wants republicans more involved
he will not support an infrastructure
bill that goes through reconciliation um
any more specifically the minimum wage i
mean this is something progressives
have pushed for they want fifteen
dollars how can you possibly get to
fifteen dollars
when you have joe manchin saying what
he's saying and republicans are on a
pretty hard line
well first i would say uh senator
manchin
and senator sanders and a range of
democrats in between
just voted to support a 1.9 trillion
dollar package that
is the most progressive piece of
legislation in history
so uh i would say we feel pretty good
about that um and the fact that
that package was not broken up it still
contained the key components that the
president advocated for
fourteen hundred dollar checks uh you
know assistance to schools
and yes there were some changes on the
margins but it is the core of what he
had
originally proposed the president
believes that there is a path forward on
a range of issues where there's been a
history of bipartisan support including
infrastructure
infrastructure improvements are not a
democratic issue they're not a moderate
issue a progressive issue a conservative
issue
the american people want their roads
rails and bridges to be reformed
he feels there's a path forward there's
no bill that's being considered
he's having discussions to hear ideas
hear good ideas from
members of both parties and once we have
a bill we're happy to have the
discussion on how we move it forward
i mean you do think that you will have
to work with republicans
do you think you'll have enough
republicans to get to 15 specifically
oh sorry the minimum wage you asked
about uh sorry you asked a few things in
there so just trying to unpack them no
it's totally fine
uh the president remains committed to
raising the minimum wage to 15
there are no negotiations right now with
the president or anyone from the
administration on lowering that
threshold
uh he's going to work with leaders in
both in
in the democratic party and anyone who's
interested in
having this conversation about how to
move it forward and the best
uh the best vehicle moving forward but
that's the status of it right now we're
focused on the american rescue plan
and just so i could follow up on a
different subject um you mentioned last
week that the president
is expected to give a formal press
briefing um
the press conference yes before the end
of the month
so you so that is a commitment before in
the next few weeks we
will see him and give him take questions
and follow-ups and so forth
yeah he he has done about about 40
q a's since he took office but in terms
of a
formal press conference which i
understand there's a big focus on yes we
will have one before the end of the
month
and what does it mean going forward will
we see
more of president by end more than 40 q
a's in the last month
or you will be submitted to more
extensive
questions follow-ups the kind of things
we're doing today
um will we see him regularly
i don't know that you'll see him more
than 40 times a month but i'll have to
tell i'm happy to ask him that question
go ahead yamiche thanks so much um a
couple questions
first on direct aid i know that march
14th was that was the deadline because
of the unemployment that was
running out is the white house basically
ensuring people that that their
unemployment that enhance unemployment
that they'll be able to still get that
and that there will be no lapse there
and also is there a concern
about what happened last time where
there was a backlog at the irs
and there was a backlog and checks going
out to people is that a concern
has that been worked on well i can
assure you having been on a call with
her this morning that secretary yellen
is focused um
like a laser on ensuring that there's a
clear process and system for ensuring
this assistance gets out as quickly as
possible
i certainly understand the questions my
friends neighbors everybody's asking me
the same thing about when they will get
assistance when this will go out the
door
uh but it is really up to them on the
mechanics of it
and as i noted a little bit earlier and
yamiche i think we've talked about this
i think
there was concern about the gap of
people in the last
with the december package that were left
out
and didn't receive the assistance and
that's certainly something that is being
factored into
the administration and the process here
but i really leave it to treasury to
provide an update on the mechanics of it
and then i know you said the pro the
president's preference is to not do away
with the filibuster
house majority with jim clyburn he said
that if democrats
want to keep enjoying the majority that
they have to find some work around
around the filibuster he said maybe it
would be a cinema mansion rule i wonder
if the president
would be behind some sort of rule for
specific legislation jim clyburn was
talking about civil rights and voting
rights
legislation would the president back any
sort of filibuster work around
for specific legislation again that's
not his preference
um and he believes uh with an issue as
important as voting rights there should
be a path forward um
to work with democrats and republicans
to get it done so nothing's changed on
his policy on the filibuster i'm
wondering i was not asking specifically
about the filibuster more about a rule
that would get around the filibuster for
specific legislation like voting rights
and civil rights
what he would he possibly get behind
that not doing away with the entire
philosophy no i understand
i just don't have you know he's not his
his preference is not to make
different changes to the to the rules um
uh
to the to the filibuster rules on on
separate issue on the border
um i understand that the delegation's
going to brief the president i wonder
can you talk a little bit more about
what was seen there what was most
concerning especially
i know this administration has said over
and over again it's not the right time
to come
they've they talked to children they
talked to officials had that message
been reached
to the to the immigrants were coming
across our borders
well you know i think first time i'm
going to allow
the president to receive the briefing
first before we talk about it more
publicly but i will also say just an
expectation set that
this is a normal part of an internal
policy process and i don't
anticipate that we're going to give
extensive briefings about internal
policy processes or
internal discussions that a policy team
will have with the president
they went there because the president
asked them to go
because he wanted to hear and understand
tangibly what's happening on the ground
and you know having sat in on briefings
with him about this issue
the questions he asks are how many
teachers are there
what specific steps can be done to
improve the processes of the timeline of
how
quickly kids get from um from shelter
facilities into homes
what's the logjam in the process these
are the kinds of things that he's
looking for more
detailed information on and i think he
wanted to hear
tangibly from people who recently
visited the facility
on the ground hence they went but you
know any policy discussion
be private as any policy meeting would
be in an administration
there is real interest especially among
people in this country
to to know more about what's going on at
the border especially when you have
unintended company minors
i wonder how i understand that there has
to be private conversations
but why not say more and why not at
least say yes our message is being
received or no we need to work more
on getting the message i would say it's
clear we need to work more
on getting the message out and being
very clear now is not the time to come
there is uh the majority of people who
come to the border are turned away
yes we are we have changed the policies
of the last administration as it relates
to unaccompanied children
but the majority of families adults the
vast vast majority
are turned away at the border and that
is a message
that clearly we need to continue to look
for means
and ways of getting out uh you know more
and more out to the region
is there time for the prime time address
completely housekeeping but is there
a time specifically for it's a great
question i will follow up
i think i know it but let me let me
double check and make sure it 100
landed on on the time i think it's going
to be well can i come back because i
just let me go ahead to the back
thank you jen um foreign policy question
as you know it has been constant
attack by the houthi rebels on targeting
saudi arabia
the wall street journal just quoting a
senior saudi official saying that
actually the attack yesterday
on the port of rasta nura was originated
from iraq or
iran is it does the white house believe
that this is a game changer
since it's not from yemen and will you
hold iran accountable
well first we continue to be alarmed by
the frequency of houthi attacks on saudi
arabia escalating attacks
like these are not the actions of a
group that is serious about
peace the attacks are unacceptable and
dangerous and put the lives of innocent
civilians at work including americans
we of course continue to work in close
cooperation with the saudis given the
threat as you referenced
that they are facing on a frequent basis
from these attacks um and we understand
that they face genuine security threats
from
from yemen and others in the region as a
part of our interagency process we'll
look for ways to improve support for
saudi arabia's ability
to defend its territory against threats
but i don't have anything
from that to predict for you at this
point in time you know update this on
the negotiation with
with the iranians where are we now i
mean this is told
is it you offering them something new
where are we well
it's an ongoing discussion about uh uh
you know based on the reaction of the
iranians to the eu
invitation we see this as a part of the
diplomatic process uh
but we don't have any uh update in terms
of a date or timeline for that
discussion
go ahead isaac thanks jen given what the
president said yesterday with the
executive order that he signed and
what's in that executive order
i wonder if you can explain why the
pushing for voting rights isn't
a legislative move on voting rights
isn't higher up on the agenda
for the president as you're sequencing
these things
especially given uh all of the changes
that are being pushed in a lot of states
too
it is it is a priority um right now our
focus is on the american rescue plan
getting it through getting it passed
because
the number one and number two issues for
the american people are the pandemic
and the economic recession but making
easier and more capable
miracle to vote something the president
talked about on the campaign trail and
he will remain committed to
uh through the course of his presidency
he signed executive orders as you
referenced
into place just over the weekend he
obviously
supports the patch in the house of this
piece of legislation
and we will continue to look for ways to
uh
make voting more accessible for the
american people he's not leaning into it
is something for congress to move on
soon is there a concern that as these
state voting rights laws get into place
and of course there are elections in the
fall
they're gonna be elections next year
that it will be sort of
those restrictions put in place in
i mean he he is supportive of the
legislation right
he talked about he put out a supportive
statement we had a supportive
statement of administration policy on
the passage through the house
it's something that he conveyed in that
he would look to see
uh he would support that moving through
the senate
obviously there's our there are a range
of means of working with states on their
own
approaches working with congress on a
range of ways to
help increase voting rights and access
and he and his team are eager to
continue to do that
thanks everyone oh sorry one more go
ahead i just want to follow up because i
want to clarify you you said that
that the policy discussion behind the
scenes with the president of this
delegation is private
i just want to clarify following up on
what yamiche is asking
i'm not asking for a detailed readout on
a private conversation that's happening
in the oval office between the president
and the delegation journalists have not
been allowed to see what's happening
inside the place
i understand and i said so all i was
conveying on that particular piece just
for clarity is
we're probably not just for expectation
setting we're probably not going to do a
readout of their private conversation i
know you weren't asking for that you had
a readout on what these
children whom we've not been able to
speak to ourselves are
saying to the delegation of 14 members
that went on
the conditions that they're being held
in or if not a readout on this
conversation on what these kids told
people like joseph can we get it
ourselves well first we
as i said when you asked the question
earlier we we are very open to
and support and the president does
providing access to these facilities we
need to do that in a way that is
protects the privacy of these kids who
are under 18
is safe given code of coveted protocols
and we are committed to doing that
so we're not expecting you to take our
word for it i was just conveying that
any private policy conversation i just
didn't want there to be an expectation
every day that
we'd be reading that out this will be an
ongoing discussion and of course we want
to bring more people in here to
shed more light on our thinking on how
challenging this issue is
on what contemplations we have to ensure
that children are in
facilities that are safe uh that help
and that we take steps to expedite the
process to get them to
homes that are either family members or
homes of people who are sponsoring them
thanks everyone
it is
you